[Музика]
Наталія Добрін, я можу сказати, що хвилина
сабаха Кашьяп проковтнути мій екстренний
бюлетень про те, як насправді фактична
волатильність матерії Ініціатива ITT це
не призма Лія так десяток дуже
незрозумілий Аллах робить те, що дає область своєї
енергії - відповідає перфекціоніст Амір
devar покажи латиноамериканцям шаріат Роджер
чіпси піранью
так хто Наталія Роджер знайома з
цим дуже дурним алгоритмом ремонту
привіт всім прийшов час
уроку англійської мене звати Наталія лешка
давайте почнемо я хотів би сьогодні привітати мого
дуже дорогого гостя привіт Наталія
привіт  як ти сьогодні, міг би бути краще,
добре, тому я сподіваюся, що вам сподобається
урок так само, як і нашим учням, я сподіваюся,
що сьогодні ми починаємо нову тему, і
для цього я хотів би, щоб ви подивилися на
дошку
і спробували вгадати  тема
розглядає слова добре,
тож це слова з нашої теми, чи
можете ви здогадатися,
Наталія, допоможіть нам, що, на вашу думку,
буде про книжкову
літературу чи щось інше  так,
так, саме ми будемо говорити про
читання літератури різних жанрів,
автори книг,
тож давайте переглянемо слова ще раз, тож,
як ви думаєте, що це за слова, чи можете ви
просто прочитати це авторе
так точно повторіть також за нами і
будь ласка  ще раз автор дякую
наступна тема тема що таке тема, тому це
може бути темою нашого уроку або
темою книги основна ідея книги
давайте повторимо тему тема дякую
наступна
Жан так Жан Жан так
так жанр  книжки
бігун фільму також добре що б ці
слова журнал так журнал повторював за
мною
журнал журнал дуже дякую добре
добре давайте поглянемо на цю бібліотеку слів,
тож я сподіваюся, що ви
знаєте слова це місце, де  ми можемо
взяти книжки і почитати, тож ти
зазвичай ходиш до бібліотеки італійською ні, у
мене вдома чудова бібліотека. Ого,
тобі пощастило, то які книги у тебе
є у вашій бібліотеці у
мене є команди даних у мене багато книг
з  журналістика і у мене є велика
кількість політичних книжок, це
цікаво,
так що за книги у вас
вдома, тож давайте перейдемо далі, і я хочу
поставити питання, що ми сьогодні читаємо
взагалі
всі, і давайте зосередимося на тому, які
матеріали для читання роблять  підліток троє підлітків
l'Italia чи можете ви мені допомогти
взагалі що ми читаємо як люди що
ми читаємо сьогодні не про дітей
підлітки просто взагалі що ми читаємо
літературу добре
так книги, мабуть, великі журнали хороші
журнали
добре нашою попередньою темою був Інтернет,
тому Наталія  це може бути підказкою для
статей з Інтернету, ви кажете, що багато
блогів також правильно,
і який матеріал для читання
читають підлітки, що ви думаєте,
я думаю, лише блокує спілкування
з Інтернетом, ймовірно, вони також
читають книги я не впевнений  що вони
читають оригінальні книги, але вони, безперечно,
читають електронні книги
прямо в Інтернеті, їм подобається, використовуючи
технології, тому давайте подивимося на
діаграму, щоб поглянути на діаграму,
ми ха  ve електронні книги газети веб-сайти
комікси журнали та книги, і у нас
є відсоток, тому переможцем є книги,
а це діаграма уряду Великобританії,
тож давайте прочитаємо діаграму
більшість людей віддають перевагу читанню книг і
багато людей вважають за краще читати, що якщо у вас
є  подивитись 60 70 % що пристойно Талія
60 % журнали мм-хм то я можу просто сказати,
що багато людей віддають перевагу читанню
журналів багато людей вважають за краще читати журнали
добре, якщо ми думаємо про 20% 20% чи була ця
газета газети чи можете ви сказати
речення речення багато людей вважають за краще
читати газети добре, і справді дуже
мало людей віддають перевагу читанню електронних книг, але
дуже мало людей, тому що ви віддаєте перевагу читанню
і як часто ви читаєте
особисто я віддаю перевагу читанню веб-сайтів
добре, я також віддаю перевагу читанню електронних книг і
газет, газет  ти читаєш їх
онлайн
чи справжні газети я люблю читати
паперові газети,
папір, одна паперова, це добре, це
насправді дуже гарна ідея, тому що
особисто мені подобається  запах книжки
та запах паперів, тож
у мене є звичка читати це
вранці за чашкою кави та
чаю, а ти читаєш газети
добре як часто ти читаєш Наталі
щодня не щодня  щодня кожен день я
люблю читати веб-сайт, а як
щодо газет, які я люблю
читати на вихідних, добре, то давайте рухатися
далі, є завдання для вас, подивіться, у
нас є визначення дієслів
різних типів книг, тому я  хочу, щоб
ви подивілись і здогадалися, добре, і ми разом перевіряємо,
тому книги про реальні факти та
події
це публіцистичні книги добре це книги
про життя відомої людини
книги біографії так, саме захоплююча
книга про незаконну діяльність,
прочитайте слово незаконний може бути
тригер для вас незаконний, тож це схоже
на кримінальний кримінальний трилер кримінальний трилер
так історія кохання
О римляни так до римлян дуже страшна
історія страшна гора гора так історія,
повна захоплення, екшн та небезпека фантазія
неможлива бу  t ми дзвонимо, тому що це
сповнене дій, це пригоди так, якщо
ми подивимося історія, створена на
основі чиєїсь уяви, веселощі це
фентезі та історія про майбутнє
космос наукова фантастика так, тож
давайте ще раз поглянемо нехудожні
книги про  реальні факти та події
нехудожня література повторіть будь ласка документальна література
дякую біографія книга про
життя відомої людини біографія
біографія дякую класичний роман
добре
стара книга класичний роман класичний роман
кримінальний трилер захоплююча книга про
незаконну діяльність кримінальний трилер злочинний
трилер дякую
романтика  історія кохання Romans Romans Hora
дуже страшна історія hora
так пригоди увага історія, повна
хвилювання, екшн та небезпеки науково-
фантастична історія про майбутнє або космічна
фантастика наукова фантастика
дякую і фентезі історія, створена з
чиєїсь уяви фентезі фентезі
добре зараз давайте розмістимо  погляд люблять
ігри так я роблю так так я не збираюся
бути схожим на ігри g  Еймс, це будуть
навчальні ігри, добре, тому ми зосередимося
на словах подивіться, у нас є
нехудожня література класичні нейрони наукова фантастика жахи
фентезі всі типи книг тут добре,
я збираюся писати слова
дуже швидко, ви, хлопці, слухайте  мені і
спробуй вгадати слова, які тобі потрібні, щоб
назвати слова добре, перш ніж я закінчу це писати,
тому Наталія, я пишу слова по правопису, і
в момент, коли ти вгадаєш слово, скажи
його швидко
добре, так служба Абуеліти, як
магазин її Далласа  лаваш Ранкін як
які поні до того, що слухають музику насолоджуються
одним, це про людей їдців
давайте спробуємо так FA і TAS чому фентезі
Браво
H o Double R orho Double R ах так
добре ро ма і три місяці так
бі ог РА біографія так
і на ІКТ та художній літературі  Bravo
CL — подвійний класичний роман, який добре бачу, як я
їм наукову фантастику. Браво
дивовижно, і ще одна гра для
вас, я збираюся сховати слова тут
десь зі мною, тому, наприклад,
науково-популярна література буде в мене на
голові  так що тут немає  художня
література нехудожня література пам'ятати документальна література тут
добре біографія я покладу собі на плече
віагра
чи він і що тут документальна література хороша
тут
біографія молодець давайте помістимо тут романтику
так що тут біографія а тут
романтика а тут фантастика
Браво кримінальний трилер я б поставив  тут
Шріла я люблю кримінальні трилери добре так
що тут кримінальні трилери а тут
біографія романтика або документальна література ммм
біографія так добре дозвольте мені покласти
пригоду на долоні Пригоди тут,
так романтика хороший пригодницький трилер кримінальний
трилер науково-популярна біографія дивовижна, з якою
ви можете грати в цю гру  твоїм друзям
або з родиною запам'ятати
слова добре, давайте йти далі, я
дивлюсь на ці слова, вони всі
букви зашифровані, тому спробуйте
вгадати слово, а Наталія, ви допоможете мені
тут для фантазії, а як щодо цієї
однієї біографії  молодець, Кора Кора, то
ось чому Рілла Рілла
наукова фантастика так Браво науково-популярна, а
цей роман про Клемона
так ні добре w  Ну, окрім цього,
яка твоя улюблена науково-
документальна література, добре, до побачення і романтика, добре - я
люблю романи про свободу, а також я люблю
кримінальні трилери, що ти думаєш про
злочини, Релліс, я не люблю кримінальні
трилери, мені подобаються книги з біографією,
куплю  біографія великих людей, це
справді нації чи щось подібне,
і це дуже пізнавально. Ви можете
отримати багато фактів із цих книг, щоб ви
могли багато чого дізнатися, давайте перейдемо до кількох
типів книг, про які ви вже сказали мені,
що вам подобається читати  ваша
улюблена книга, про що вона,
то чи можете ви назвати одну книгу останньою з
улюблених, давайте спочатку з улюбленими
AHA в
цьому році, це про Трампа, насправді
це цікаво, добре, так це про
його життя чи про його, це про його
шлях до  президентське крісло ах, це
справді цікаво, добре, так що ваша
улюблена книга, давайте йти далі, у
нас є питання, більше питань
, тому я сказав вам, давайте зосередимося на
улюбленій, тому що тут ми збираємося
у вас є запитання про останню книгу, і я
хочу, щоб ви поставили ці запитання про
вас і вашу сім'ю, ви стежите за нами, ви
відповідаєте на питання про вас і вашу
власну сім'ю або друзів, давайте почнемо з
номера один, що ви зазвичай читаєте,
ви щойно згадали, давайте переглянемо  Наталя
читає сайти газети та книги
правильно правильно, а що про вашу сім'ю чи
вони зазвичай читають мій чоловік зазвичай
читає газети та сайти добре мій
великий син зазвичай читає свою літературу
це про економіку, йому 20
років і мій маленький син зазвичай читає
трилери, будь ласка,
сім років  старого okay О комікси змішує,
що робить дійсно чудовим добре, скільки
часу ти витрачаєш на читання, оскільки для моєї
маленької дитини це приблизно за годину
до того, як він піде, Девакі лягає спати добре,
а про мене я навіть не можу сказати, тому що
це все  протягом дня це дійсно
добре як для моєї дитини, так і для мого чоловіка
те саме стосується і моєї,
як і мого сина, так само, як і для мого
чоловіка майже половину дня до  e
робота та після його роботи це дійсно
чудово,
скільки часу ти витрачаєш на читання добре
де ти читаєш вдома в автобусі чи
на дорозі чи, можливо, в машині в
кафе, де ти читаєш скрізь
скрізь, і, можливо, це
злочин, але в машині я також читаю
книги, у
нас паморочиться голова ні ні, це нормально, тому що для
мене це новий світ для тебе, мабуть,
паморочиться голова, коли я, коли я в машині і
починаю читати, у мене паморочиться голова,
так багато пристрасних не  добре номер
чотири, яка була остання книга, яку ви прочитали, ви
розповіли нам про улюбленого Белтрама, а що
щодо останньої книги, яку ви прочитали,
це остання, це те саме, так
, є дві книги про Трампа, добре,
ви знаєте, що зараз читає ваш чоловік,
я  Знайте, що це не книга
про прогульників, про які говориться, можливо,
це щось із сфери
побудови ага, це добре, тож давайте знову перейдемо
до ще одного завдання для вас, і ми
збираємося розгадати кросворд, щоб ви могли
взяти  ваш телефон сфотографуйте
це  кросворди, і ми збираємося зробити
це разом
тут, і ми разом перевіримо, Наталія,
і ми полегшимо вам це, тому
це більше грубо і чотири вниз, дякую,
тому давайте спочатку почнемо, ми перейдемо,
тому ми"  повторно під номером один, який розповідає про
книгу, яка розповідає про чарівний світ,
фантазії так, ви запишіть у
кросворді, ви можете записати, використовуючи свої
зошити або зошити я збираюся
написати на дошці Наталія, ви заповнюєте
так,
число  одна фантастика гарне номер два
книга про злочинну діяльність
це номер три Наталія вручає три
одну так кримінальний трилер кримінальний трилер
давайте з номером восьма книга, яка
містить захоплюючі несподівані події, тож
Наталя допоможи мені з цією пригодою так,
група погоджується,
звичайно, добре  дозвольте мені змінити число,
щоб не було плутанини, але наступні
слова були номером три, а це був
номер вісім, добре, давайте зробимо це так,
тому що вас можна сплутати з
числами, давайте з номером дев'ять,
тобто приблизно  справжня історія книга про
правдиву історію наукової літератури так, тож давайте разом перевіримо, що
номер один — це фентезі номер три кримінальний
трилер номер вісім пригодницький і
номер дев’ять документальна література.
місце в майбутньому
Наталія, що це може бути наука
так наука і друге слово виберіть
якусь хорошу наукову фантастику
давайте заціпеніти номер чотири книга, яка
дуже лякає для жахів так браво
книга жахів зараз книга, яка цілком
популярна, але все ще популярна правильно 5  /5, починаючи
з C так класичний роман класичний роман
добре, це п'ять правильно так, перший
ммм-хмм класичний роман, потім слово номер
шість книга, яка розповідає про історію кохання
шість шість, ми йдемо вертикально, так що це романтика
так, роман хороший і номер сім  книга
з географії так, дуже дякую,
тож давайте разом перевіримо, що
номер два – наукова фантастика номер
чотири – жахи
номер п’ять – класика номер шість –
романтика і номер сім біогр  aphy ви
можете перевірити зі мною подивіться чи у
вас така сама Наталія
так у мене така сама фотографія Браво класна
студентка, тож будь ласка, нагадайте мені, що тут було,
я добре, я допоможу вам це
номер шість, що тут було роман роман
що було тут на моїй долоні я сподіваюся, що ти
пам'ятаєш, це мій друг, пригодницька
пригода,
який він був твій зріст, а тут
документальна література Робін або щось із
жахів чи трилерів, кримінал,
справді молодці, я збираюся перевірити вас ще раз
перед домашнім завданням, будь ласка, пам'ятайте  слова
зараз давайте обговоримо Анталію, ти любиш
фантастичні книги ні, мені вони не подобаються,
вони для мене нудні, добре,
тож давайте з кримінальним трилером, ти
любиш читати кримінальні трилери ні, я
втомився від них, бачиш, я можу"
я люблю кримінальні трилери, давайте
перейдемо до пригодницьких оповідань - я люблю
читати пригодницькі історії, коли я була
маленькою дівчинкою, коли я була в школі, мені вони
дуже подобалися мм-хм, тепер вони вам більше не
подобаються,
тож давайте перейдемо до наукової літератури  це
історії  про справжнє життя чи правдиві історії,
тож ти любиш читати науково-популярні книги
я люблю добре читати науково-популярні книги,
і давайте поговоримо про кілька слів, які йдуть
вертикально біографія Я пам'ятаю, що
це твій улюблений, це мій
улюблений Жан, хороший друг  давайте йти з
класичними романами люблю читати класичні
романи я читав велику кількість класичних
романів, коли навчався в університеті, я
бачу, що все добре, тож давайте далі подивимося
на діалог, що ти читаєш Сьюзі,
це фантастичний роман, який називається «
Охоплення мети»  Філіп Пулман,
про що йдеться, це про дівчину, яка живе в
дивному всесвіті, це добре, так,
це чудово
ти підеш
з нами,
тож Наталія, почнемо, ти будеш
я. Я буду B добре,
що ти читаєш Сьюзі, це
фантастичний роман Філіпа Пуллмана «Золотий компас»
, що розповідає
про дівчину, яка живе в  trange
universe, це добре, так, це чудово, я
не можу відірватися,
зараз деякі слова зникають, тому ти починаєш,
що ти читаєш Сьюзі, це
фантастичний роман Філіпа Пуллмана під назвою «Золотий компас
» про що
він про дівчину, яка живе в  дивний
всесвіт, це добре так, це чудово, я
не можу від нього відкласти, і більше слів
зникає добре, що ти читаєш
Сьюзі, це фантастичний роман Філіпа Пуллмана під назвою «
Золотий компас
» про дівчину, яка живе у
дивному всесвіті  це добре, так це
чудово, я не можу від цього відкластися добре, і
останнє для тебе Наталія, ти можеш прочитати
всю історію, що ти читаєш Сьюзі,
це фантастичний
роман Філіпа Пуллмана "Золотий компас"
про дівчину, яка  живе в
чужому всесвіті, це добре, так це
чудово, я не можу відмовитися від цього
фантастично дуже дякую, тому ми рухаємося
далі, і ми збираємося створити подібний
діалог знову Наталія, щоб полегшити ваше життя,
я даю вам пізніше, тому ми
створити порівняння  у діалозі ми можемо використовувати ідеї
звідси, тому ми зараз використаємо пригодницький роман
і фантастичний роман, це буде
вашим домашнім завданням, добре, тому пригодницький роман
«Втрачений символ» і корисний
словниковий запас можуть допомогти вам подивитися,
висловлюючи позитивні думки, то що
ми можемо  скажи, що це чудово, це фантастично
або це дивовижно, номер два, мені це дуже подобається,
це дуже гарний вираз.
словниковий запас
дійсно багатий, тому чоловік цього телефону
Наталія, який твій улюблений я не можу відмовитися від
цього
так точно висловлюючи негативну думку,
так що можна сказати, що це насправді не так добре
або мені не дуже подобається
це нудно повільно  або нудно, і
книга мені не дуже подобається, так що якщо
вам не подобається книга Наталія, що
б ви сказали, що вона нудна, це нудно,
добре, тож давайте створимо подібний діалог,
і ми використовуємо пригодницький роман, давайте
почнемо я  я буду цього разу і
йо  ти будеш добре, то що ти
читаєш у Наталії, це пригодницький
роман Дена Брауна під назвою «Втрачений символ, до побачення
», про
що йдеться про історика, який повинен
слідувати стародавньому символу, це хороші роки, я
можу»  Запишіть це
фантастично, і ви створите свій діалог, який
ви зможете прочитати з нами, або ви можете зв’язатися
з друзями чи зі своєю сім’єю,
і давайте, зараз час вікторини, і
ми збираємося перевірити вас, тому виберіть
правильний варіант, Наталія, ви можете  допоможіть мені,
чи рекомендуєте ви цю книгу
добре чи так, це чудово, яка
правильна відповідь
так, це чудово, номер два чи вам
подобається номер книги відповідь a
це пригодницький роман відповідь BI не можу
відкинути,
яка правильна я  не можу відмовитися від цього
Браво номер три ти любиш читати
комікси відповісти eh я не дуже люблю
їх на Sabae це не так добре насправді
я не дуже люблю їх фантастичний
номер чотири ти віддаєш перевагу науково-
фантастичним романам відповідь  a так, вони
чудові відповіді B це дивовижно
y  es, вони чудові,
це фантастично, і номер п'ять - ваша
книга гарна. Я часто читаю кримінальні трилери,
це трохи нудно, це трохи нудно
тут документальна література
дякую біографія роман, а тут
пригоди добре,
тож давайте знову придумаємо макарони кримінальний
трилер пригодницький науково-популярний біографія
роман Брава
дуже дякую ти можеш зробити це швидше,
ніж Наталія я впевнений, що зможеш, тому ваше
домашнє завдання, хлопці, наступного разу
правильно  діалог пам’ятайте, що ви
використовуєте інформацію зі слайд-
фантастичного роману «Заводний ангел»
Кассандри Клер, підлітка, яка намагається
врятувати світ, і ви використовуєте модель,
яку ми використали в діалозі, якщо ви
не пам’ятаєте діалог, не хвилюйтеся,
просто перемотайте назад  відео, і
перед вами буде модель, якщо ви
просто швидко не візьмете телефон і не
сфотографуєте його, і ви запам'ятаєте це,
щоб я чую дзвінок і  зустріч,
нам потрібно зупинити урок,
дуже дякую Наталія, мені сподобалось, дякую,
це була чудова фантастична пригода,
тож побачимось наступного разу, і ми
продовжимо розмову про книги, до побачення
[Музика]
Шакіра розриває нового Камю  так, Вергіл, я
мав би сказати, Лобо Немо, Муша, так,
вітаю, о, боже, о, так, подивіться на цю
Італію Томоко злий Аліса скористається
провізією професора так, Донателла
Баччан, так, так,
що вона не мала б газу, і каже, що
VSO Kaku — це Матільда Ковак, Лада Ніва, кр
суня  я Малайзія це ще
фантастичний нейро Blazers mashup shit
Ileana Bishop Adama tenemos la Y
personas знання через chemos Луїс -
так - kaduche Showtek якщо вона живе
чесно
круто
[Музика]
ти